who does your makeup
is is your hair your own natural color
um
wow and they want to know well
when you had surgery
have you got the same as me and the
answer is yes but i don't have the messy
bits
[Music]
i struggled with growing up
with my childhood
because i knew from the age of six that
i was trapped in the wrong body the
saddest thing is is i used to get up in
the morning
look in the mirror
and didn't see
the person that stood there i was
looking in the mirror and seeing back
somebody totally different were your
family aware of what was happening
no
my family wasn't aware of what's
happening because i was the oldest it
was assumed naturally that
oh you'll get married you'll have
children and
and from from my family it was kind of
like
not expected but it was kind of
that's how their
upbringing was my dad was very a macho
action type dad
um because he was a firefighter and i
tried to suppress these feelings and i
struggled i found it very hard
what made you want to then go and work
for the military
um
i just wanted to get away from where i
was where i lived it to me i was like
you pee i've got away from home yeah
and that kind of it was another journey
it was like another doors opened and
let's see where we go with this
what was it like to serve in the navy
um
it was it was very
it was very tough in a way
um obviously it's a disciplined service
um
it was very great because i went and
went halfway around the world saw
fantastic countries and that but it was
very hard as well because
you couldn't be gay or lesbian or trans
and that's where it's very hard
for someone like me
to be the real me to be janice and it
you you had to either hide those
feelings or suppress them and and people
actually got punished because it they
got found out that they were gay or
lesbian
different various witch hunts and
they've been arrested and they got
thrown out the navy
um some of them lost medals over it
and that was right across not just the
navy but all the audits armed services i
used to go away
every few weekends and dress up and be
me and
go and visit different places i knew i
could be me and it was very awkward
it did cause me a lot of pain a lot of
anxiety
a lot of unhappiness
a couple colleagues always want to know
why i seem to be
either very sad or very upset or
kind of very
angry type but not
over overtly aggressive but just that
little bit of
anger
can you recall when you told your team
in the navy that you wanted to
become janice yes i can remember it very
well
and that was such
that was a an amazing
day when i done that and how i've done
it was i just put an email together
and i sent it to
everybody that was in my branch
specialization which was gunnery in the
royal navy
and i sent it to all to them so they all
got this email
and i titled the email rumors rumors
rumors because there's a lot of rumors
going around at the time people thought
i was a male prostitute people thought i
was doing drugs if there was a million
one things the opening line was uh hi
folks just to let you know
contrary to belief the rumors that are
going around and i listed them for male
prostitute and drugs and that said all
them you're totally off the scale you're
far wrong
this is what who i am i i want to be
known as janice i'm a person who's
suffering gender dysphoria
and
and i want to go on this amazing journey
of uh changing my gender and
transsexualism and i said and i said to
him look if you want to know me that's
fine
if you don't know me have a nice life
and and just leave me alone
and i sent that on a friday morning uh
friday afternoon i jumped on a plane and
time when i got back there was like
phone calls
emails and a million one questions my
boss just went what have you done
explain
uh and i just felt well it was the only
it was just i said to him it's the
easiest way to get it out there and
explain to people it helped and it was
people that i'd served with i'd done
training with phoned me up said oh don't
forget jan you gotta put the toilet seat
down the usual military human banter
you can't have pints anymore you could
have a wine glass or half pints or and
things like that and it was that
military humor
and
that's what got me through a lot of
things what was it like serving as
janice
joining a ship and serving in the navy
as janice
yeah there was quite a few people i
hadn't seen for a few years and they got
the name wrong and if they were more
upset about it than me and i like that
but actually serving on the ship i just
remained professional and done my job
um
and that was it i to me there was no
problems you wanted a
chief gunnery instructor you got a chief
gunner instructor and there was females
going through at the time
petty officers and chiefs doing their
training coming through to be chief
gunners and petty officer gunners so
it was no problem i couldn't see the
issue
some people kind of got a bit upset and
got caught up in the issue because they
didn't want
person that person or
whoever it was on board their ship and
things like that so
i think the individuals made it more
problematic for themselves than it was
for me um when i splashed when i served
on on the on the ships i served on
it was curiosity obviously there was
people saying well she's a tall woman
and
and people always ask me questions quite
a lot women very
curious what do they ask you well they
asked me was
who does your makeup
is is your hair your own natural color
um
wow and they want to know well
when you had surgery have you got the
same as me and the answer is yes but i
don't have the messy bits so they're
kind of like wowzer a little and they
then they want to explore that sexual
bit and say well what's sex like and
things like that uh
and i'd say to him i'll let you know
when i find the right prince i've got
kiss quite a lot of frogs yeah and
things like that
but they it's the normal talk that
females have and and
and and they're just really interested
and some guys are really interested i
get a lot of guys more frightened they
stick their fright to me
um in
in reality i'm more frightened of people
um
because i've had to put those barriers
up and everything else and and be very
protective other people the ones that
didn't want to understand who chose not
to
fully embrace it or didn't want to know
i kind of left them on the wayside and
they're the one there some of them were
the ones that i had problems with i had
the issues with
with the abuse transform phobic abuse
whether it be physical mental and verbal
would you mind just
giving us some examples of some of the
prejudice and discrimination i had hate
mail i had death threats i had the press
handing me down i people stealing my
washing i'd
food tipped all over my head everything
and i took it with my stride and the
waitresses and the chefs that's
witnessed it and they were civilian they
were civilian people these people i
remember when the lady sent me
don't cry do not cry in front of them
janice because they've won
and she was right and it all come to
head one day was uh the warrant officer
in charge of the mess
got wind of
different things happening and he didn't
know all the stuff that had been going
on
and the chefs and the civilian chefs and
the waitress staff come forward one by
one and told him what was going on in
his mess
and he was absolutely devastated that
was happening and he didn't didn't know
and didn't realise and he said to me
well why didn't you tell us and the
reason was i said to him if i come and
told you why create a scene why get the
military police involved why why make
everything unnecessary even more painful
than it has to
be
did you feel like you'd still made the
right decision coming out as janet
yes
yes because
i felt
having all all the skeletons in the
closet it made me ill
keeping everything as a secret living a
double life it made me ill
and i wanted to be totally true and
honest to myself
and
my family my immediate family did
struggle with it my mum who passed a
couple years ago
she struggled with it she struggled she
could not come to terms with me being
janice
my younger brother decided not to speak
to me for 10 years
but we're talking now um and and that's
a fabulous thing and my dad
once he realized what i was doing where
i was going and what i wanted to be
he then realized wow and he looked back
at the pictures and gone there were so
many times she was trying to tell me
says who's grown up
and he's always wanted a daughter so
he's got his wish and it's like my
daughter's been in the royal navy my
daughter does this my daughter does that
and and it's you know
some bits he don't he still struggles
that today and it's i think it's modern
day because
he's 83 and he's that generation where
some of it he can understand and some of
it he does struggle a little bit
you made you made history and became the
first transgender woman in the navy i
just look at him i just like no i just
wanted to be janice and
and that's it and
it's quite humbling
and i don't mean to put that down or
anything and you're right i did make
history
i think when they lifted the ban on
homosexuality in the armed forces in
2000
i then realized i could actually
make it possible and become janice i was
one of the first
serving chief petty officers in the
royal navy
to go from male to female gender
reassignment so in some ways you could
say i brought the navy from the 19th
century to the 21st century and one big
flashbang wallop here is janice
so after 25 years what made you decide
to leave the navy uh i i had to retire
um i didn't want to leave the navy went
look you
in your early early mid 40s um you've
done 25 years and you had to leave i
left the navy and then i
struggled trying to fit into civilian
life um
got an oppressive cv and i found it very
hard
to get into
into a job that i wanted to do try to
pursue a career as a as a licensed
bodyguard
i am licensed and i've kept myself
current
but the problem had been is
when when i wanted to go for jobs people
didn't either take me seriously or they
saw me cv and gone
overqualified
or
we don't think you'll fit the job
and some of it was especially in
security industries when they do a
background check my old name used to
crop up or so
trying to get work
and being taken senior seriously a
female bodyguard has been very hard
because the trans issue pops up time and
time again and
that's where i struggled
would you have a message for
somebody in the military who was going
through something similar to what you
went through
from 2000 onwards to now
they've
there's a lot more tolerance
with people a better better
understanding
i think it's helped because there's
organizations in the military
that fully understand it and
and the royal navy is as i can't see any
approach enough they got a thing called
compass and it's run by a group of
of
officers seniors and junior rates and
it's run and most of it's in their own
time they do that
so
there's that cohesion and understanding
when i look back now and i look back at
my service of 25 years for queen and
country
yeah i i i've done anti-piracy in
arabian golf i've on the merchant ships
i've done
rescuing getting european nationals out
of libya
in
so i've made history
but i've also made history being janus
although i've made history i've been
part of history and and it's quite
humbling because at the end of the day
there's no winners or losers
yeah i'm still here i am me he's janice
[Music]
my now just right mandy break right and
i i slam my throttle fully forward
really quickly i just rolled to 120
degrees i pulled really really hard
towards the ground he immediately
started pumping out flares and they act
as a decoy to the surface-to-air missile
that had just launched and it had locked
onto my engines